[Music]
this week's cover story plan z looks at
an up-and-comer of french politics a
controversial journalist by the name of
eric zemor he's already polling higher
than marine le pen but his critics
accuse him of being a far-right
candidate and often compare him to
donald trump
so who is zamor
freddie gray the spectator's deputy
editor pens this week's cover story and
he joins me now alongside jonathan
miller who writes about as a more rally
he attended last week
freddy tell us about eric samura who
hasn't even declared his candidacy yet
well it's a bit of a joke really that he
hasn't declared his candidacy because
everybody knows
uh that he's running uh and he appears
to have quite a sophisticated operation
behind him uh and the reason we at the
spectator know about this is because of
the the brilliant jonathan miller who's
about to start talking
uh and he has been on this story for the
spectator ahead of everyone which means
that back in march um we ran a piece uh
saying that he would be running and to
take him seriously as a possible
presidential candidate
uh and when jonathan first suggested it
i thought this seemed a little bit
eccentric and a little bit out there but
he's been proven
uh brilliantly right because
zenmore is emerging as a very serious
presidential candidate
and there's a lot of comparisons with
donald trump there are some good points
of comparison there
because the phenomenon is is quite real
and he's a very mediogenic personality
um but he's also got a more serious
streak and as i'm trying to say in the
piece
um
and i'm not the first to make the
comparison but as i try and say in the
piece he's actually a bit more of a
boris johnson-like figure in my mind in
that he's a he's a first-rate mind he
writes his own books
um and he's a patriotic thinker who
seems to fail upwards hmm
well we'll come back to his ideology and
these comparisons certainly but first
jonathan as freddie says you've been
writing about zamor for the magazine for
months now he's a journalist term
politician you recently attended one of
his rallies what was it like
it was amazing i went down to bezier on
saturday night which is the
ancient wine making capital of occitani
here in the south of france
to the zingerzanga theatre
where i found
an hour and a half
before his
speech was even scheduled to begin
a vast crowd of people stretching around
the whole building
and i
took the opportunity from my training as
a
reporter to go around and talk to as
many of them as possible and i found an
almost fanatical degree of enthusiasm
for eric zamor who is this
you know piano
uh so-called
algerian jew
[Music]
in the heart of what was once national
front territory
inspiring
you know a couple of thousand locals
to show up and share him to the rafters
um
and he did he delivered a remarkable
speech
i think freddie's right that he's got
you know
this trumpian
ability to somehow
get people to
stamp their feet and clap their hands uh
with delight and he's got the kind of
the wit and the error edition of boris
yes some of that too
um
but i think he's also got um
an analysis that is playing very well
with the french who are disillusioned
with macron disillusioned with marine le
pen as her
as his preferred opposition
and who are looking for a
something fresh
um
i think they find his analysis
analysis of the social crisis
in france makes him a little like
douglas murray of our own parish
who uh
you know and there are many points of
convergence between the strange death of
europe by
douglas and uh the susied francaise by
uh
by zamor so there's some of that too
um and i wouldn't
hesitate from saying there's a there's a
little bit of thatcher in him or quite a
lot because he's he's a culture warrior
he
he um his his view which he expresses
forcefully
is that the kind of woke groupthink
that is infesting our universities and
schools
public institutions public broadcasters
government
that
the it is the duty to go out and
confront that
um
intellectually
and for this he's been called a racist
an islamist
islamophobe
he's characterized continually as the
extreme right
by the bbc by the times by the guardian
by the new york times
he's a much more complex guy than that
but freddie these accusations have been
levied at him and with some backing he
has been convicted of inciting racial
hatred if brits have heard of them
they're likely to have heard of him as a
far right candidate so perhaps your
comparison to boris johnson or
jonathan's comparisons to the spectators
douglas murray wouldn't go down so well
with the people we've actually compared
him to
well but possibly not i'd say his his
rhetoric is more uh blunt than boris's
perhaps but he certainly he just like
boris he has a back catalogue of
articles
and books uh that anybody could pour
over and find lots to be offended by he
said a lot of very provocative and
shocking things but we are now living in
a slightly different political moment i
think now where
politicians can succeed
not in spite but because they say
shocking and provocative things and it
makes people sit up and take notice and
it makes the media engage with them and
what's very interesting with
uh those of media reactions to more and
particularly the foreign media reactions
as a more
foreign to france
is that they have this strange thing of
being angry about how interested they
are in him so you see a lot of articles
uh berating publications uh for showing
so much interest in him which is it's
quite a funny dynamic but it's how a lot
of populists succeed
um and it seems to be how zamor is
causing so much
uh aggravation and interest in this
presidential race
jonathan uh you recently noted in your
article that you've spoken to french
voters who intend to vote for zamor but
have previously voted for
sarkozy or macron
perhaps that's a good comparison to the
obama trump voters which certainly
existed in the united states uh in 2016.
you also said just now that it's more of
a nuanced discussion whether or not he
is far right but how have his views
changed or what's different from when he
was convicted well the far right label
is a very easy label for anybody
on the left to apply to anybody on the
right who they don't really want to
argue with and they'd announce them as
far right it means mean zamor's
convictions are very french justice is
very instrumentalized and french
magistrates
uh and its trade union are very
left-wing and they use
prosecutions to deabolize to demonize
their political opponents and this
offense of inciting racial hatred which
is exactly the same one that the
scottish nationalist
party is trying to force through
north of north of the border is one that
is is pretty vague i mean the truth is
that there were blacks in the line to
see zamor
zamor speaks
sincerely about how muslim families are
the victims of disorder
in uh in in in areas of france that are
that are dominated by
by these gangs um
and uh i don't think he's a racist i
think it's i think you know every
anybody nowadays can be called the
fascist just for disagreeing i doubtless
margaret my mother thatcher is called
fascist of course
um but i think he's as much of a fascist
and a racist
as she was i
not one at all i think his his power
is rhetorical and intellectual
and he has a style
which is um
is and isn't trumpian it's trumpian in
that it cuts through
he has a he has an extraordinary way
with the french language
um
but it's not trumpian in that you know
there's a real it's not slogans he's not
demonizing his opponents or calling them
names or fat or stupid or anything like
that he's he's saying how successful
they are and how uh
the biggest rounds of applause in bezier
frankly he said you know the left is out
of power but it's ideas march on the
right
um has been in power 40 the last 60
years in france but they've just
capitulated and that's why the
institutions are going and he very much
focuses on this
idea of of you know uh
paul
rasi you know group think
and uh in critical race theory
and wokism
and he's saying francis had enough of
this and he doesn't want any more of it
and his a and he says the job of
politicians is to get into office and
and not
consider that they've succeeded just by
winning an election but then to conduct
a an ideological struggle and this of
course is what thatcher did and that's
why i think that of all the comparisons
um made for zamor he is the margaret
thatcher that france never had he's the
guy
who potentially could shake things up
but first of course he has to you know
get to the second round which is not
easy and then he has to beat macron
which is going to be even more difficult
so you know this this is
a strong point you know i mean he's by
no means
won the presidency at this point
freddie what's the zamor ideology what
are the policies that would come with
his election and is there such thing as
a typical zimmer fan
well uh immigration is a is obviously
the the the big the more talking point
and has been uh
for quite a few years
um but his campaign the people behind
him are very keen to stress that he's a
lot more than that he has quite a
detailed plan for the economy that
involves
cutting inheritance tax reforming
corporation tax he has a perform he has
a plan for reforming health care he also
wants to do away with macron's vaccine
passports which will be very popular
with a large section the america of the
french public
uh and he wants to increase the size of
the military
and so make good on some commitments
macron has made
uh he also wants to get out of nato's
integrated command structure which is
quite an interesting symbolic move
uh and i think the idea behind that
would be to reset
a relationship with russia between the
relationship between france and russia
um and not have the sort of
what some people call sort of reflexive
western anti-putinism
um so he has a lot of ideas
as for who the typical zimmer voter is
that's a very interesting question and
one i think jonathan is better placed to
answer than me but it seems to me that
they are slightly
upper more upper class than the classic
foreign national voter and i realize
that's a snobby thing to say but the
fact is there's always been a snobbery
towards uh marine le pen and her family
they're seen as sort of uh deplorables
you know the the voting place is a
deplorable voting debate and macron
doesn't seem to have that problem as
jonathan has noted a lot of his crowds
are sort of young affluent
people um he appeals to secular liberals
he appeals to catholics
uh and he appeals to small business
owners he has the ability to appeal to
lots of different people because he
seems to be something new and jonathan
in the polls zamor now leads le pen why
is she losing out to him is it for
freddie's reason that um certain people
just feel like it's more okay to
identify with somebody
pen voters are aware that the le pen
brand has has
overrun its course her father
lost well i think five elections
she's lost two on the hop
she's kind of an idiot you know she was
eaten alive by
macron and the debates last time here
economic policies incoherent
she's attempted to make her party more
centrist but nobody believes it
um she's hopeless and she's lost
basically half her support since june
she's gone from you know
25
28
to 12 14 depending on the polls and
still i mean you might you might
fundamentally disagree with her i think
that she's gone about what she wants to
achieve the wrong way but i mean she to
say she's an idiot i mean she has been
quite influential in french politics
she's really put the pressure on no she
hasn't been she's just she's been very
convenient in french politics
for uh for ensuring
as the fifth republic was designed to
ensure that uh that you know the
moderate centrist
you know moderate writers gets in power
and this is how and so she her
entire track record is one of failure
she you know the night the front
national
the the rasamblamon national didn't win
a single region in france not one in in
the most recent regional elections
um
you know uh
even her militants even people i know
who uh have supported her in the past
say and say you know aside from anything
else she's a loser but you know as for
you know the idiot charge i'm really
happy substantiating that you know i
just refer people to the videos of her
debate with macron where the her
absolute incoherence on the you know you
know on the future of europe
um and and and france's role in it uh
was was was
he he he crushed her bones and made his
bread um and uh
she she's terrible on television
um i would add one thing to what freddie
said of what you know what we're waiting
for you know we're waiting to see if if
if uh if some more can attract the 500
sponsorships he needs to you know get on
the ballot willing to see if some more
can raise the 15 million
or so euros he needs you know to mount a
credible campaign and pay people
um and we're also waiting to see
where he emerges
on on on the really fundamental issue in
france which is uh the eu because
in in 2005 the french voted by 55
percent not to sign the constitution
the government ignored them
and implemented it anyway calling it the
lisbon treaty and this is a fault line
in french politics which still exists
and on which i think zamor is likely to
find himself on the side of those saying
the 2005 um
referendum what he he's saying
the 2005 referendum needs to be rerun
now if he means it
he's saying we can reintroduce
referendums into french politics
and we're gonna politicians are gonna
have to trust the people to make
decisions um this could be very very
revolutionary so maybe we're a kind of
one of those not infrequent french you
know pre-revolutionary revolutionary
periods or maybe we're not i mean to be
to be realistic macron you know has
still got the the money he's still got
the media you know he's still got
control of the institutions um so he's
still
the favorite but but the more is is is
you know the the flavor of the month and
um
and we're on it
freddy as jonathan points out there um
this is by no means
if and it sounds like when he does
declare his candidacy that samoa is just
going to sweep this election and the
odds are still stacked against him but
on jonathan's charge against le pen if
she was convenient in french politics
from your reading of the situation do
you think zamora might really stir the
pot
i think it is hard to say i mean his
campaign is still embryonic it's his
the people behind it still call it a
pre-campaign
so it's yet to be born really but i
think
it clearly has a lot of momentum behind
it and a lot of interest and enthusiasm
which is not something you can say
about marine le pen and and to repeat
marine le pen has always had the baggage
of her father and the baggage of her
name she's never quite been able to cast
that off
um zimmer does not have that and he will
be called
anti-semitic even even though he's
jewish he'll be called racist
he will be called a fascist and a nazi
um and it may be that a lot of this will
stick to him because he has said so many
provocative things in the past
but for now
it looks like he's got serious momentum
behind it jonathan this week you've also
written about another influential
political figure that is running for the
presidency michelle barnier who our
viewers will certainly know how is his
presidential bid going
well you know as you could tell from
that piece which was in the spectator
coffeehouse blog today i i i didn't do a
lot to hide my negative feelings about
barney but i have to say that my
conclusion is that barney is not going
to be the next president of france and
that i can tell you okay that this week
i try to count up the number of
prospective
candidates for the presidential election
in france and there are more than 40 of
them and that's not even counting
zamor nor macron who hasn't yet
officially announced it is running again
so
um we have uh you know we have you know
a grand national kind of sepal chase
with tons of fences the one thing you
can be certain about in french politics
is that french presidential elections
can be very unpredictable and that's how
we got macron because who saw him coming
um
and uh i can't think i'd like to claim
that i did but you know
but you know there are this there is
this um track record of you know
favorites falling at the equivalent of
the political equivalent of breeches
brook
and breaking their legs and so
with this two-round system
um
macron's preferred opponent has always
been marine le pen
because he knows he can
you know eat her alive
um
but zamor is his intellectual equal at
least and they're both really smart guys
so you can look forward
you know if zamor does make it
into the second round the the debate
between zamor and macron
um could be very decisive and as a
consequence of that
oddly we could find president zamor
although without necessarily a majority
party in the national assembly or the
ability to control the civil service so
i think france looks uh
you know
potentially quite uh dynamic at the
moment
[Music]
you